you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up playing a
5-2 game let's um I play e6 maybe too
much let's try let's try g6 and try for
a dark square strategy on Knight f3 well
scratch that I was going to play Bishop
g4 so let's go with this knight c6 and
then this idea of a six rook b8 and then
b5 I wonder about playing h6 right now
h6 r h5 hmm I'm gonna go with h5 weakens
g5 so I have to be careful of this I may
be taking the knight out if he arrives
on a three h3 scratch that let's try to
recreate b5 ya on h4 night 8 night h3
I'm going to give up my LightSquared
Bishop for that night he could be a
great pest on g5 so let's see if Knight
here this masks b5 so can I not just
clamp down on g3 I'm going to go for
that maybe night h5 to g3 I have this
strike I'm not sure if I want to go and
for that right now
hmm my knight might be kicked soon with
this I don't have the e5 square anymore
if this move I think I could play Knight
a5 mm-hmm
actually no I can't I get trapped with
the b4 hmm
do I need to play e5 right now or maybe
e6 you know thinking more about East six
like OE 5 F takes G takes d5 if I five
takes twice with the pond
I don't think I'm too concerned about
that should I go in 45 let's give this a
shot yeah let's go in for that the
Queen's the leader so I'd be different
if this rook if the Queen and rooks
position was switched around a five
wouldn't be good son takes I couldn't
take back so let's see be fine with the
Queen trade at the end if they have
double isolated pawns I should be able
to hunt to hunt that pawn down
I'll see though I'm a time edge usual
usual case yeah if I wasn't careful I
think this and I didn't have this square
cuz the bishop observes it and on push
here be four I think my Knights just
gone I don't think I'd have any
compensation I know that this is a
pretty committal move for white to make
since this is where their King resides
but yeah I'd be down a piece they got a
beefy Center here okay no Queen trade oh
I didn't even consider that I guess on
Queen e7 Bishop c5 Queen e7 Bishop c5
queenie 695 pretty scary do I need to
play Bishop d7 maybe Queen e7 Bishop c5
queenie 695 I can't take because of
context and I'm in a fork additionally a
knight on d5 is threatening on c7 I
think I need to play Bishop d7 as
awkward as that is okay
not a fun move to play for sure you know
this isn't too great I wasn't thinking
that that move would be played doesn't
this help me some I wonder if I should
even take probably maybe this push I was
considering a night move right away
mm-hmm I guess I'm going to drop that
pawn on h4 so I might be alright without
or even I could consider Bishop here
although Queen takes 8 Queen takes that
I still have some pretty good dark
square control considering c6 just to
keep the knight out of d5 but if I can
maintain this night the night will watch
over that mm-hmm I think I want to get
rid of their dark square Bishop hmm let
me do that Bishop takes us with Czech
Queen takes Knight Queen takes Queen
Bishop's pinned so I'm expecting Queen
takes h4 here I'm giving up a pawn but
again I guess I'll be trying to show
that this Knight is worth something
we'll see how much that is worth that
Queen takes h4 they're gonna be up a
pond but maybe material isn't that big
of a factor since we are basically on
opposite wings with our Kings I could
still be I wasn't expecting that we
could still be looking or I could still
be looking into this move mmm
thought I just lost a piece barely close
to doing that a double attack here rook
and Knight I got a play here
hmm may have just a blunder to piece
straight up I think I have to do this
you know a Bishop e2 now hmm okay well
I'm now going to be down hmm the
exchange at least hmm under a minute I
think I have to I don't think I have
anything gotta go for that and how to
recapture exactly Knight takes I'm on
the Queen Queen h6 is very active what
else do I have I guess I have to go for
this and I guess here and it's
threatening Queen here stuff my knight
is there to defend the bishop some down
the exchange okay I was expecting the
Queen's to still stay on board I have
still some dark square control it's
clearly not going to be enough hmm
okay let's take here they could consider
taking here and they are going for that
I have any tricks here I don't think so
well let's see if my Knights can manage
anything I have to play g5 if Brooke to
f1 I have a fork here you see the
elimination show that C pawn that means
the knight on d5 is going to be a
monster let's see if I could put up any
resistance here bringing down the
exchange and a pawn
highly doubt it at f/4 move really uh
was really strong okay
noted can I not just grab that pawn
let's grab a pond and a babysit that
night maybe g5g for and start racing you
know nights are tricky
to watch out for forks I'm glad he's not
in the center then I'd much rather him
in the center if he's removed I'm
basically dead for sure
hmm I could think about night f4 and
then night h3 but I'm leaning more
towards just maybe even sacking upon and
letting my H pawn become past something
much more direct in other words let's go
for it care less about these guys
there's no way I could try and defend
against these threats over here on the
queenside yeah let's keep going okay you
know let's keep pushing hmm keep going
okay hmm I can maybe take here didn't
see that move
rook takes pawn King g8 they could throw
in some checks g7 I have to move my king
Knight takes rook I get a queen with
Czech gotta come back over oh they could
just take right now yep time to resign
the rook is behind that passed pawn as
well I didn't hit confirm mmm all right
GG let me go into the analysis f4 as
soon as f4 hit I was clearly the worst
side wonder if I could have done
something a little bit different around
here
I know I've I've experimented with h5
before I'm pretty sure the computer
would suggest this in this position but
I'm not really so big a fan of allowing
this clear plan by white which is to say
this Bishop h6 move in exchanging dark
square bishop s' and then going for you
know this mmm yugoslavia tack
like you would see in the Sicilian
defense h4g for h5 so h5 prevents in the
quick exchange of the dark square bishop
s-- and i played rook to b8 pretty sure
that this is an idea a six rook b8 and
then this b5 move yeah I guess right
around here after h3 I suspect that this
is where there's some improvement my
eyes I must say immediately lit up when
I see h3 because I see this as a hall
and I'm trying to clamp down with h4
like I see this is like a nice mm-hmm
you know it's it's a desirable pawn move
to clamp down on the g3 square and look
to you know anchor a knight in there but
I think there's going to be some shift
here this is where I could improve
something other than this h4 move
because the reply f4 is really strong I
think let me put on the OH
the engine I think right around here I
could certainly use its help the arrows
are on so right at this point it's
suggesting Knight h5 which is surprising
hmm
am I not just losing a piece my concern
was this okay Knight there rook here
takes takes
interesting I have this move and there's
no time for this because I'm on c4 I
didn't see this idea in the game night
h5 is threatening Knight g3 I'm not
winning material but the resulting
position eliminates this LightSquared
bishop which is allowing the reply well
it's it's allowing me to meet this d5
move with Knight a5 where I am throwing
some punch if I'm just to do something
like quite natural like castles this is
much different because on d5 here I'm
not threatening this Square and so b4
can hit although surprisingly enough I
guess there's still crazy stuff
happening
you notice the evaluation here I guess I
could play this position still down a
piece b5 on takes here and then Knight
takes Wow yeah that get pretty crazy but
the main point here is that I just
didn't see this idea where the knight
can actually safely go to a5 I didn't
appreciate this variation where I could
take out the light square Bishop the
defender of c4 and and land on a5 with
some tempo hmm so that really messed
with me some not seeing this idea play
d5 and now just worse he fives no good
takes takes Queen f2 was a strong move
Knight to d7
I played Bishop d7 and this is the
problem Queen here yeah is crushed
because of what I mentioned in the game
this is too much +3 so unfortunately I
haven't worked myself into a pin Queen
f2 was a strong move exchanging Queens
he leaves the pressure I really don't I
didn't have too much concern about this
being down upon because I could get him
back a night here and then I could scoop
him up this is strong square for the
night watches over c7 yeah
well this was the downfall right here
right in the middle game it's uh not
seeing this idea of Knight h5 into g4 in
meeting d5 with Knight a5
okay so I don't think I had any well now
I still have some chance mmm tactics
I want Bishop h6 and this is a losing
move because of exactly what white did
Queen no 5 you know I don't think there
was anything from there
but this said I have an opportunity for
Knight g4 mmm and you know what I could
also take out that dark square Bishop as
well suppose Queen here or here to
defend the bishop I could take the
bishop although it's suggesting f6 in
the bishop is trapped yeah but on Queen
here you know if I really wanted to I
could take here and then play Bishop
here and none takes I could recapture
like this and yeah I would certainly be
a fan of this position over the one in
the game for sure
I like having control over this ie 5
square one that could be challenged at
this point but still you know it's a
it's still a game for sure mmm and even
in this in descending I see this as a
potential long-term liability for white
one that they have to watch over because
of my bishop pawn fixed on a light
square his eyes kind of light up yeah
this was a middle game mm-hmm
I didn't properly assess this 'if I've
advanced and they came up with a strong
reply Queen f2
avoiding the Queen exchange and now that
the D file is opened up this becomes
this looks really really awkward rook to
b8 I should mention that the idea with
this you know rook to b8 is if this
Knight is playing here I can already
consider a move like b5 you know the
knight here is obstructing the bishops
view of b5 you play b5 and then you know
go in for this kind of stuff
but uh yeah didn't quite come to that
point it didn't quite guy I didn't quite
get in the v5 move things heated up in
the center I had to really see this
Knight h5 move and I didn't he five you
know and just take it a little bit
further I didn't see e5 nor this optical
idea of Knight to g4 how could I have
seen that he is unprotected
mm-hm Knights on the same color squares
the Queen likely make a move and throw a
punch of the Queen okay just making
mental Health's for myself here and from
this point it's busted just flying
through some one and a half yeah if I
think this was the right decision to
take the bishop and activate the rook
they're taking with the pond of course
it's still good but it's the better
decision to do to take like this because
I have this I have this square from my
night I'm throwing a punch at the pond
and also I could play c6 and kind of
keep the night under control he has to
reroute and I don't have to worry about
the rook entering in the 7th at least
right away clearly white is still the
better side here bring up the exchange
but you know this is this is getting
into this is certainly an important
decision which piece to take at this
stage you know would you be taking like
this or would you be activating your
rook that's best they went with this
well also because they're winning
another they're winning some more
material wrapping on c7 and he's super
significant because now I cannot keep
out Knight to d5 although that was never
even played in the game but
hmm that's kind of weird it only says
point seven advantage oh my goodness the
rook is trapped I did not see that this
backward move Knight to e6 this trick is
actually trapped huh
how do you like that
Knight to e6 Wow totally did not see
that one neither did my opponent hmm
there's still the better side but I
guess I do get that guy back okay didn't
consider that at all I took the pawn and
it is back to even Wow play Knight to f4
and you Nunn Knight takes rook I have
Knight III man okay and so I guess there
were were some opportunities even though
I lost that material after Queen to f4
the N Bishop T or well I should say
Bishop to e2 takes rook there were still
some opportunities for me I guess even
around here just being down upon yeah
now it's just completely busted I guess
I have to return rook here what's wrong
with rook there these checks
wow what a crate what a messy position
tough to calculate easy to go wrong here
for white know what these uh with these
Knights around in this pawn to step away
from cleaning I think they could have
maybe even done one better some
somewhere around here I wonder if there
was a better approach because clearly
we're seeing you know a spot where
there's opportunities for me to make it
a
a little bit more difficult on white I
wonder if there was some cleaner
approach for white so that they're not
even having to worry about the past H
Pond Lake g5 I just started pushing
guess hm-hmm and suggesting here if the
rook could get behind yeah I guess it's
a little bit tricky you know with with
this very direct play I have here
pushing the Jeep on I guess I will end
up with the past H pun by devoting a
knight to defending against that past
prawn I guess is quite all right
yeah no I don't think there's any mmm
big improvement let's just say with how
white could have converted this
end-to-end game you know I think it's I
think it's good and you hear from here
it's just busted after a check rook
right here and they're threatening me
they're stopping this and they're ready
to just scoop up the rook I needed to
throw in the check but we're looking at
+8 now plus 9 okay well play and learn
huh I could use some more work with this
opening for sure g5 no good or at the
very least on this f4 move I have to see
this idea of Knight to g3 hunting down
that LightSquared bishop and then have
this idea in mind Connor play against
the c4 pawn and maybe even then later on
I could finally follow through with that
b5 advance okay well as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video in
the comment section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you